I'd like to talk about specialty inks
that are used for security printing one
of the reasons that you use special
links is if you need something else to
do on the package already this is a good
example of what we call pre conductive
inks if you look carefully it looks a
little bit like gold it's going to be
very difficult to show on camera because
of the the reflectivity of the material
if I've got a package that I want to use
as for example in antenna I can turn
this into a conductive antenna if I use
a conductive ink if I want to click
together to small microchips that are on
the package I might want a conductive
ink that's there
is actually one of my patents is using
one of these as the antenna for the RFID
so this would enable a large retailer
like a Tesco or a Sainsbury to buy just
a single RFID at bulk rate get hundreds
of millions of these sometimes billions
of these and they don't have one-hour
fighty that can be read from 30 feet
away one RFID that can be read from 10
feet away those that segments what
they're purchasing and they pay more per
RFID chip
now they buy one RFID chip and the ones
they only want read from like an ear
field type of an approach they don't put
any conductive ink on the packaging the
ones they do they put a conductive ink
on the packaging and use it as an
antenna and that makes it be readable
from 30 meters away instead of 30
centimeters so they actually gauged the
readability of the RFID in terms of
distance by the ink they put over it not
by the RFID chip this ties into the
continuum of doing what we call pre
compensation so for colors for example
we will print out a series of colors and
then see what happens after we capture
them on the device that's going to be
used to read those colors later what
happens often is you'll get color travel
you'll actually have a color that may
have been a very strong red shift a
little bit towards orange and so we will
do is we'll print that red out initially
with a little bit of extra magenta so
that when it actually goes through that
color travel it shifts directly to red
color travel is also used in other forms
of security printing like on bills
you'll see on US bills something that
looks green and when you shift it it
shifts all the way to magenta
that's called a hundred and eighty
degree color shift because it's just 180
degrees in color space so from a
computer science standpoint why these
special tanks are so important to us
will often have inks that have
particular types of chroma color
information or other information that's
in there
that is a very powerful computational
aspect to it I mentioned color travel
let's say for example I've got these two
oranges you can see here this orange the
original printed one when it's been
copied is actually a little bit more
yellow in colored space let's say the
orange is right here
yellow is over here I've traveled about
five degrees in color space what I can
do is if this is important to me to read
this as orange I will add a slight bit
of red
this and now when I get the color travel
it locks right in place at that orange
instead of over in the yellow this is
called spectral pre compensation so what
you have is you have a large set of
colors that you print out
you basically image and then using your
computer algorithm you dis you determine
which of those colors when it actually
travels ends up in the color you want it
to be in so very powerful parallel
computing that goes on to be able to do
to do that on the fly for all of the
labels that come in there so the color
travel is that travel as in a difference
between what you think you're gonna get
what you actually get or is it something
that happens over time or as it happens
over the print great set of questions
there's there's actually three different
types of pre compensation that you want
to do and you alluded to two-and-a-half
of those so the first one is the actual
color travel where I have because of the
way I image this it immediately has a
different color than what I want it
because I can't image that because of
the differences in you know in in the
CMOS imagers that we're using for most
of our cameras now those will not read
the colors exactly as they were printed
the second one you alluded to which was
kind of cool is does it change over time
absolutely and there will be ones that
you'd particularly know are going to
fade over time so if you want those to
be legitimate you can have that you can
add some other color to them so that
they'll fade properly and stay as a
color or you can use that as an
indicator that something is being reused
right so you can intentionally have
something that will change over time so
that if the product or if that code
that's associated with the product
should only last 18 months in 18 months
time the image is faded enough that will
show as non-legitimate
really good question the third form
which is probably not as interesting but
does take a lot of computer science is
what we call structural pre compensation
so if we look at this packaging here
this is a very small barcode here this
is actually a data matrix barcode that's
inside of these color tiles that data
matrix barcode is often hard to read
with a mobile camera most people have a
mobile camera in their pocket and so we
want them to be able to read those we
will actually do something called
structural pre compensation to make that
read best what happens when you read
with one of these cameras is you'll get
a bit of blurry and so if you've got a
black pixel
use a big example here if I've got a
black module there which is one of the
little black pieces in that barcode it
will show up like this after the blur so
it'll jump like this so what we do
instead if we want it to be that large
in the end we actually print a little
bit of white along the side and make it
that small so the camera reads the black
part as exactly the right size and we
get the right contrast between white and
black I've done testing on this if you
don't do the structural pre compensation
it can be copied three times over until
the read quality is as poor on the third
copy of a copy for the counterfeiter as
the original structurally precount
and so these have all been structurally
pre comps so that they are small enough
that it makes it difficult for somebody
to copy you'll basically anticipating
the blur that the camera will put in
exactly so of reversing that a little
bit so that that blur will be correct
and then obviously a copy of that won't
have the same properties is that exactly
right so if you have the original one
there the first time you image it it'll
show up as legitimate if somebody now
makes a copy of that they'll have lost
that structural pre compensation and
that will blur larger and they won't get
as good of a read off of it and so if
you're checking read quality if you're
looking at read success rate any other
type of thing like that that's gonna
show up right away and the supply chain
and people are gonna be complaining that
they can't read the barcode or something
or you'll even see the anomaly just in
the number of successful barcode reads
when you're monitoring these on the
backend service even if it goes from
like four percent success rate to three
percent in other words four percent of
people actually read their barcodes here
three percent here that might be a
significant enough statistical
difference for me to know that
something's gone wrong with the barcode
so we always look for anomalies in our
data this is sort of a from the
computing side a lot of the work that
we're doing on the back end with the
data this is truly big data
I mean HP will have hundreds of millions
of these cartridges sold every year
we're looking for deltas of you know
0.1%
as being significant in terms of
possible possibly sniffing out a illicit
activity in the supply chain just
putting these in place all of this
taking a lot of computer you know
computer design for this you put
structural spectral and temporal pre
compensation in place
it allows you to have a label that's
optimized for the security program that
you're trying to put in place you'll
wonder what's different in each of these
I've got a different hidden mark which
is called a covert mark or digital
watermark hidden behind these sort of
solid tones in each of these places